let us now look at some examples of
sample spaces sample spaces are set and
the set can be discrete finite infinite
continues and so on let us start with a
simpler case in which we have a sample
space that is discrete and finite the
particular experiment we will be looking
at is the following we take a very
special die a tetrahedral die so it's a
die that has four faces numbered from
one up to four we roll it once and then
we roll it twice we're not dealing here
with two probabilistic experiments we're
dealing with a single probabilistic
experiment that involves two rolls of
the die within that experiment what is
the sample space of that experiment well
one possible representation is the
following we take note of the result of
the first roll and then we take note of
the result of the second roll and this
gives us a pair of numbers each one of
the possible pairs of numbers
corresponds to one of the little squares
in this diagram for example if the first
roll is 1 and the second is also 1 then
this particular outcome has occurred if
the first roll is a 2 and the second is
a 3 then this particular outcome occurs
if the first roll is a 3 and then the
next one is a 2 then this particular
outcome occurs notice that these two
outcomes are pretty closely related in
both cases we observe a two and we
observe a 3 but we distinguish those two
outcomes because in those two outcomes
the 23 happen in different order and the
order in which they appear may be a
detail which is of interest to us and so
we make this distinction in the sample
space so we keep the 3 2 and the 2 3 as
separate outcomes now this is a case of
a model in which the probabilistic
experiment
can be described in phases or stages we
could think about rolling the die once
and then going ahead with the second
roll so we have two stages a very useful
way of describing the sample space of
experiments whenever we have an
experiment with several stages either
real stages or imagined stages so a very
useful way of describing it is by
providing a sequential description in
terms of a three so a diagram of this
kind we call it a three you can think of
this as the root of the tree from which
you start and the end points of the tree
we usually call them the leaves so the
experiment starts we carry out the first
phase which in this case is the first
role and we see what happens so maybe we
get a 2 in the first role and then we
take note of what happened in the second
role and maybe the result was a 3 so we
follow this branch here and we end up at
this particular leaf which is the leaf
associated with the outcome 2 3 notice
that in this tree we once more have a
distinction the outcome 2 followed by a
3 is different from the outcome 3
followed by a 2 which would correspond
to this particular place in the diagram
in both cases we have 16 possible
outcomes 4 times 4 makes 16 and
similarly if you count here the number
of leaves is equal to 16 the previous
example involved a sample space that was
discrete and finite there were only 16
possible outcomes but sample spaces can
also be infinite and they could also be
continuous sets here's an example of an
experiment that involves a continuous
sample space so we have a rectangular
target which is the unit square and you
throw a dart on that target and suppose
that you are so skilled that no matter
what when you throw the dart
it always falls inside the target once
the target once the dart hits the target
you record the coordinates x and y of
the particular point that resulted from
your dart throw and we record x and y
with infinite precision so x and y are
real numbers so in this experiment the
sample space is just the set of XY pairs
that lie between 0 & 1